my relationship with tequila is that it
is my shot of choice and when I have one
I have five cheap tequila always has
this weird cheap tequila tasting me
visually there's nothing to go off us
I'm gonna shoot it because that's the
only way I know how to drink Cheers
kind of burns but I like it that like
didn't last as long as it normally does
as more of a sins Oh God I don't want
this in my body is as bad as I imagined
it but the smell is horrible like this
was good I'm going first shot expensive
second shot she was help I've just seen
a second one too
this is the more extensive oh yeah this
is amazing yeah it's probably like $80
that was smooth as [ __ ] is this Drano
much better now that is a tequila you
can't taste this is good this is better
than the last cheap one yeah but this is
cheap damn this is so good though
Oh smelly huh I just grew up in here
that does not smell expensive might
throw up actually if that's not Cuervo I
give up all knowledge I know about the
killer
it smells like yeah like throwing up in
the back of a taxi there it is there's
that face that's good that's [ __ ] nice
whatever this is I want to know really
smooth this is the cheap tequila this is
the expensive aquila without a doubt in
my mind I agree with that
no I hope to god that's the fancy one I
can't believe I didn't recognize Jose
Cuervo
this is Cuervo come on are you sure you
didn't mix this up I like to kill it I
think a little bit
you've changed a life today you know
what tequila makes me want to hug oh
really this is happening